look at me the drop is I am the double
for Nightcrawler one of the most
interesting parts about doubling
nightcrawlers thanks to today's sponsors
Squarespace stay tuned to the end of the
episode to learn how to get 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
hey welcome back to another episode of
stub man react we're here with Jesse la
flair he's a parkour and freerunning
master I've been referred to as the Tony
Hawk of parkour yes so Jesse's actually
been in a couple different videos that
we've made in the past besides that I've
made a career in the stunt industry
we're gonna take a look some clips here
and Jesse's gonna hopefully shed some
light on the world of dynamic movement
so I'm excited so this is David Bell he
is essentially the creator of parkour I
like how he's not wearing a shirt so
that you can tell he's never wearing
wires because I'd kind of be like
totally against the whole thing he made
right yeah it's to be strong and be
useful
oh that right there is so classic so
fast dude that's so smoothy catches like
right at the base it swings him in I
love that it's like I want to do that
like that looks so good
lab that lighter so fast
it looks like he's like he's yeah
believe that it's just like doing this
and like it's actually really really
sketchy yeah cuz we had to climb down
this super sketch ladder to get into
this tunnel for the spooky short I would
like it had the backing to it and I was
still just like yeah just think about
like locks and the octave locked in
three points of contact at all times
what is this yeah he's going like this
dude so what's the secret to landing
from a height drop like that so the the
deep squat but also letting your sort of
quadrupedal movement right like using
letting your arms anticipate some of
that impact as well so you not just like
trying to take it all you're like
bottoming out and letting them so
dispersing that forest huh yeah really
just dispersing it there is something
and be said about like the air flare
like rolling down the windows it I think
it's relatable to anyone like you know
that feeling of like whoa you have
enough time to like well a couple times
it's like oh that was a drop I think is
it is it because like you jump and you
start leaning backwards and you could do
this - yeah yeah a little bit swimming
yeah
yeah like how parkour is already
invented by this guy just so happens the
two goons chasing him also part of why
this scene is so good is because they do
tell the story of movement right like if
they don't have someone that understands
where the danger is where the
technicalities are they don't tell the
story right and you miss like all the
value in the movement that shot coming
from the angle the roof it's sketchy you
have this gate with spikes sticking out
yeah you have a death drop on the other
side and he's literally jumping to a
corner which if he overshoots he's gonna
go past it without this angle this shot
would not look nearly as cool as it does
does it helped his landing him like
thicker gravel oh yeah that material
like giving way breaking apart like
that's why the gap is like kind of
doable is cuz it does absorb a lot of
your impact look how much of the rocks
shoot out when his legs and feet hit I
wouldn't be surprised they added a
little bit more up there when they did
it so this gap is super famous it's
called the manpower gap and it's been
done now by hundreds of parkour athletes
people have done gainers from flips
there's now a fence they put up yeah
which didn't make a difference people
still jump over it now the fence
I mean most times I get to work on a
chase scene they show me this or Casino
Royale my god we want something like
this so when you saw this Jesse you're
like this is my calling I mean this and
matrix really watching major it sounds
like what free so parkour is efficiency
and freerunning is the flips
realistically it was just a different
name used on a documentary and then it
kind of took on a life of its own in the
forums there was all these arguments
about it all but parkour is you're being
fast and efficient getting from point A
to point B by going over under or
through any obstacle that's in your path
freerunning is more like the
self-expression of movement can't be a
free runner if you don't do parkour so
all these foundational movements are
needed in order to be a free runner in
that space and express yourself and
learn tricks and flips and all that as
well
these days everybody's got subscriptions
you got your Netflix subscription you
got your Amazon Prime subscription you
got your subscription to some weird
internet service that you probably want
to talk about but you know what
subscribing to our channel is free so
why not hit the button so now we're
gonna jump into x-men apocalypse whoo
and you are the Nightcrawler double flip
I am the double for Nightcrawler man you
know you can teleport it's called BAM
fing
one of the most interesting parts about
doubling nightcrawlers the actor Kodi
smit-mcphee
incredible dude were really good friends
he has some back issues it restricts him
at certain times from doing somewhat
basic movement so all of this is pretty
much mean he actually did get dropped
when they dumped him into the scene
right away well what's crazy about this
you're seeing puffs of smoke what you're
actually seeing is 12 or 13 different
marks I'm in a wire I'm in a harness
you're on all these things you're
getting pulled into a line we have 250
background actors and then I do it again
do it again do it again watch the movie
I did not need to do any of those you
cannot tell that I physically hit those
things this smoke is in the way right
it's just there's light hours we're
talking about hours of me just hang in
there and just getting railed into the
fans over and over again you don't even
get to see the meat or the technicality
or the flight or this thing in the movie
it's literally just puffs again does
Jesse need to be there they put me up
there put me against the fence pull me
back and then had a front line where
they pull me into the fence and then let
a little small explosion go off as if I
was being electrocuted so boom hit in
the fence
[Applause]
I mean the most interesting stunt in
this whole thing is this wrap around the
pole so when I start there's a lot and
pulling me under but there's also like a
limiter that's not letting me drop past
a certain point dude that is super cool
so before doing Nightcrawler I had no
wire experience like besides like a
couple like poles right but nothing like
acrobatic because you're used to like if
I'm gonna do a front flip on ground my
upper body is generating the rotation to
get the flip you know wire it's like
it's more of a balance point so if I
want to do a front flip in a wire it's
actually like pulling my knees up which
then makes the up my arms heavier starts
to drive down and then you have to
counterbalance that it's almost as if
knowing how to do a front flip is gonna
make it harder for you learn how to
front flip own crazy okay cuz you're so
your muscle memory is telling you like
this if you do this on a line you're not
going anywhere you're literally just
sitting there this was the last x-men
film that just came out of Dark Phoenix
that's a steep roof it's it felt even
steeper up there to be honest and the
idea was that we would hold each other
and then try to control each other
staying into that role and then drop off
of the roof into a mat when we first got
there what we had rehearsed the mat was
actually only like maybe three feet away
from the roof on the day they go let's
make the draw up eight feet something
like that
they do a camera rehearsal and when we
did it boom we rolled down bang we go
into the mat and it was just like
immediately she's like I broke my leg
her leg got essentially as she came off
the roof her leg came past her this way
and we continued to go past it this way
and it just boom bones sticking out of
the boot and for someone that likes
specializes in parkour and freerunning
and like lives to move you have these
moments and stunts where you realize
like this is real like this is my career
is on the line every time I do something
for a film and kind of even worse you're
like at the end of the day we have to do
it again cuz that wasn't on camera she
wasn't ready she's obviously going to
the hospital her stunt career is now put
on hold for however long it's gonna
potentially take her to get back from
that if she's motivated enough to like
fight through those injuries that next
day they said I were doing the roof
thing again we're just gonna put so and
so in a wig and you'll do with him okay
get back up there and do it again
[Music]
if there are any incredible stunts that
you would love to have us break down
with a professional please leave a
comment below with your scene your TV
show your movie doesn't matter we'd love
to take a look it's a great getting
inspiration from the comments all right
back to the clips guess you said you
love slides so he figured we show you
the longest slide on film would you do
this Jesse would you do this this is a
number that feeling like when I first
saw this I was like what dude if you go
head over and just start tumbling out of
control you just clip in each one of
those little ridges as it goes that's
the part that's even crazier because he
can't he can't control it with his hands
in those parts nuts look how big the
drop is do you guys think he's not on
the wire I don't know how you would get
the the running piece that like that
would not happen more than a step before
you went straight to your face I feel
like he's on a wire I don't know I guess
there's no way to paint out the wire
this isn't in that era this is all what
you see is what you get well there are
pieces of it where I'm like okay it's a
lot slower than I think it was yeah but
then there's pieces like that we're like
he's flying so Jesse is professional how
sketchy is this if there's no wire it's
like it's super sketchy that's just like
yeah it's just dead out of like weird
sliding on things experience to like the
more you do it the faster it's getting
cuz you're wiping all that dust away
it's almost the opposite with the glass
right like that filth almost slows you
down that's a very unique thing that you
know about sliding on glass what do you
think about those people that go and do
like the if I screw up yeah there's a
dude Oleg cricket that's like literally
doing rolls on a skyscraper and barely
catches his hands to like hang them and
look cool as hell and you're like why
you're doing this for views man when
it's not about the death-defying risk
and it's more about the pushing the
limit of the control and mental barriers
like that's where the parkour side of it
is
really about like it's about control
where the other thing is about almost
being out of control
yeah I'm not about that life hey guys
now I know you might have seen my
parkour stunt real and I gotta say I was
impressed with that myself I thought I'd
come out here and take a moment to work
on my freerunning real freerunning is
the creative manifestation of parkour
and courtesy of today's sponsors
Squarespace I'm gonna be showing you
guys my best
freerunning moves and while I'm at it
I'm gonna show you how each move is
representative of something that
Squarespace can do for you this first
move I call long Shante after
Squarespace is beautiful award-winning
templates that give you traffic
overviews allowing you to check your
users page views and page trends over
time this next move I call the double
entendre Squarespace is simultaneous
posting feature that's right
Squarespace will allow you to
authenticate your social media profiles
like on Twitter and Facebook and make
one post on your website which
simultaneously formats and posts on
those other social media profiles it's
pretty incredible
this next move I call a mountain to
Squarespace is multiple contributors
tool which allows you to give selective
users selective access via your website
manager you can have one guy over there
working on the marketing you got one guy
working over there on the stats you got
one guy working on the graphics all of
them can have separate permissions and
access thanks for watching guys I hope
you learn something if you're interested
go to squarespace.com slash corridor
crew and get 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain thanks for
watching my real whoa if you want to
follow Jesse's working and follow them
on pretty much any social media platform
right Jesse yeah just Google Jesse la
flair I learned a thing or two from his
videos he's got beginner intermediate
and advanced parkour moves go check it
out Instagram as well as Jessica Flair
Jesse thank you for being on the show
yeah it's been a pleasure
I appreciate it there's other stuff yeah
keep killing it I love this series man
thank you it's been fun